[Music]
a small and intimate affair at cape town
city hall to celebrate a man considered
a giant in south africa's history the
city of cape town holds an interfaith
memorial he cannot be human without one
another
archbishop desmond tutu who despite
being at the forefront of the anglican
church was known for embracing all south
africans
and so people of different faiths and
backgrounds gather albeit under covet 19
restrictions limiting the number of
people in attendance
verily from allah do we come
and back to him shall be our final
return
we pray that the legacy of great leaders
such as
archbishop de montutu always be kept
alive
for those here including the
archbishop's family this is a tribute to
a legacy that for many is immeasurable i
have spoken of his abiding faith and
hope
but what of his love which was the
greatest of these
and the loudest of his life's messages
outside the city hall is lit up in
purple a colour synonymous with the man
simply known as the arch tutu's funeral
will be held on new year's day and
according to his wishes with as little
pomp and ceremony as possible ahead of
that his body will lie in state for two
days for people to pay their respects
familiar milo al jazeera cape town